what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 15th of november the joint is
brought to you by
onyx.com listen
the best supplements in the world i've
been doing business with them for close
to 12 to 13 years
i love the alpha brain i love the shroom
tech
immune and the energy i love new mood uh
ana is a great company alpha brain is
their main
supplement uh if you try out for
branding you don't like it
you get your money back and you can keep
the product you're like joey what's
alpha brain it's the tropics for your
mind it'll make you more focused it'll
make you sharper
and it's led me to you guys this is part
of my therapy i've been doing my alpha
brain the black label which is a little
better than the original
alpha brain comes in powders it comes in
already made drinks and honor is also
responsible for kettlebells club bats
you know mct oil they have such a great
selection of things i can't remember all
the great stuff they have but do me a
favor go to honor.com right now
press in joint and get 10 off
any supplement and remember
monday next monday
is on its black friday monday cyber sale
60 off of [__] everything you
understand me knock yourself out right
now
go to honor.com take a look at their
supplements
start
2022 on the right foot let's get some
alpha brains so you're gonna have the
best [__] year of your life if you
don't like alpha brain
keep it
tell on it and those pay you they'll
send you your [__] money back who's
better than honored.com nobody go to
honor.com and press in joey or join and
get 10 off delivered to your
[__] house the joint is also
brought to you by zip recruiter i told
you guys a couple weeks ago i put like a
fake resume in there
and they hit me up with ten things every
day zip recruiters the real deal holy
feel and here's a fact for you right now
there's over 10 million job openings
like i told you 10 million job openings
but only 7.6 million people looking for
work so if you got a job opening you
need
and above and beyond to get qualified
people companies are doing everything
they can to get people to work for them
free child care work from home massages
yoga everything if you need help
building your team do me a favor whether
you got a big company or small company
go to ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates
with your job and present them to you
you can easily review your
recommendations and invite your top
choices to apply
zip recruit is so affected that four to
five employers who post a quality
candidate
get somebody within the first day no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
and now you can try zip recruiter for
free what are you talking about free go
to ziprecruiter.com
joey.ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire let's get this party started
it's monday we got no time for fun and
[__] games here
ba-boom
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
greetings you bad [__] uncle
joey here with the joint it's monday the
15th of the month
we're at the [__] halfway that's it
we got six weeks left in this [__]
year
six weeks left
in 2021 i'm fired the [__] up
my dick is hard thinking about 2022
seriously man it's been a [__] uh
roller coaster so i just want this [__]
to [__] end
and let's get this [__] started
i'm expecting the surge
in december like it's surging all over
the country so we're gonna get a little
surge in the east coast once everybody
goes inside
but we'll be alive and kicking by
february
you just gotta [__] you know don't
get yourself and no corona
situations in december and january so
you can see santa claus i mean i don't
even know santa claus is going to show
that [__] he has to show a proof
of vaccination
so to get into most states so i don't
even know if [__] santa's gonna
do what he's supposed to do it was a
great weekend i'm sorry about the
generator noise
the power went out and the [__]
neighborhood a tree went down
all you could hear of [__] generators
in my neighborhood thank god it was the
first thing i got when we got here we
got here on the first of september
and we ordered a generator on the fourth
because
they told us that power goes out the
trees go down these [__] don't
[__] the tree yeah i'm down here like
you know what's that dude that used to
live in the mountains jeremiah johnson
like [__] trees everywhere but
what are you gonna do they go down you
[__] uh you live and we got the
generator let me tell you something i
went out last night it was [__] dark
i mean when that you could really see
the difference what street lights do for
you and it's already dark down here as
it is this is [__] darkness in the
edge of town
but last night with no power holy [__]
all you were living on was high beams it
really is a [__] uh
weird adventure thank god i didn't do
[__] this weekend i mean i did the usual
stuff with the family
the ufc was [__] great two weeks in a
row
yair rodriguez against [__] max
holloway i did not bet the fight i
didn't even bet yesterday i just wanted
to watch
that fight i was busy
and i sat down and i got home for that
fight i think it started a quarter to
six
and i gotta tell you those two [__]
guys i take my hat off to them
that was a hell of a [__] brawl they
beat themselves up with everything with
the kitchen
sink with the foot
oh my god dave his foot looked like mine
about just that it looked like my foot
without the fungi toe i mean it was
[__] huge
the fight was just spectacular and i'll
tell you uh i was one of the first
naysayers of the ufc
when they went to fight island i didn't
think they could pull it off i got to
take my hats off to dana white he's done
a great job and i'm sitting there
watching this fight
and all of a sudden for some reason you
know the fight's over i'm gonna eat
dinner
and i'm about to go upstairs and my
buddy uh
called me goes go on twitter look at
some chick that pissed on a guy
in some [__] concert in daytona beach
holy [__]
i was in shock how much piss came out of
that [__] monkey that poor guy he's
dead he drowned i don't know everybody
keeps talking about the disaster in
astro world what about the disaster in
dayton that shake with that god knows
what was in a piss fentanyl
what the [__] guy was on the floor
whatever but but when i went down that
uh
when i went to look at
billy's post about the chick
i saw this [__] video
of conor mcgregor
mad dogging the tv
like the tv was on with max holloway and
conor mcgregor had his [__] chest
flexed and his back flexed
and he's just walking
back and forth looking at [__] max
holloway like saying [__] and i'm like
this poor bastard this poor bastard
doesn't know
that this sport
isn't waiting for him anymore like they
do like by that fight last night what i
saw
two nights ago saturday night that
[__] fight i was like
where the [__] is conor mcgregor gonna
fit in all this
is he gonna fight max holloway that
that's not gonna [__] happen i don't
even think he could hold his own against
yahya i mean
you know time is just passing you by
that's just to let you know dog you got
injured or something like this in sports
and i've said it before whether it's
the ufc the nba the nfl whatever the
[__] it is like i never knew that
the longevity of a running back was
three years i never knew that
when i found that fact out i [__]
died i was like
that's it
so that means like the guys that i
follow like barry sanders and [__]
all those guys i liked when i was young
the guy from the dallas cowboys and all
those guys they were like one of 20.
like you know how hard it is to make it
in the nfl you're like one of [__] 20
and that's why you have to take care of
yourself like you know all those great
players that i like you know uh the guy
from [__] san francisco not joe
montana but the receiver jerry rice i
mean there weren't running backs and
stuff like that but now you understood
why they took care of themselves like
around it wasn't just a football season
like those guys got to lift weights they
got to [__] go to yoga you have to do
so much to be at that elite level of
professionalism because that's what
happens injuries
an injury can set you back so [__]
like
i go to jiu jitsu i'm an old [__] man
i go to jiu jitsu but i know
that if i don't lift weights and i don't
do a little bit of yoga from time to
time and i don't [__] stretch at
night
i know i could pull something like i did
two years ago with the [__] hamstring
i walked out of the house with a tight
hamstring
if you have a [__] board and you
freeze that [__] you know it's
easier to break it'll just [__] snap
and that's what happened to my [__]
hamstring so that's why i stress there's
so much it's like there's so much to be
a stand-up comic
it's just not you know i thought when
you got into stand-up comedy that you
just walked up on the stage and cracked
jokes i didn't know about the writing i
really did if you guys think dog i knew
nothing about the mechanics of stand-up
comedy but i always thought that a guy
just called the club
i said what are you guys doing tonight
oh nothing
we're just down here [__] eating
[__] ribs at all this is joey diaz
i'm gonna come down and do like 48
minutes do you have a camera uh we could
dust one up it's in the basement
all right see if you could tape it
because i want to [__] send it to hbo
tonight i thought that's what it was i
really did i didn't know that you had a
right you had to work out you had to go
out on stage every [__] night and
then when you get to that level of
comedy like you're like okay i'm doing
great i'm writing i'm doing this but
then you start drinking you start
[__] the waitress you start [__]
lying to the booker and now you get the
other end of comedy which is
the f you know now is when you have to
put the brakes on and go okay that's
what i'm gonna do that's not what i'm
gonna do i'm not gonna [__] wait
i'm not gonna [__] the owner's daughter
i'm not gonna do this i'm not gonna
snort coke and you see what works for
you after a while
you know you just see what [__] goes
but
three four years ago you know how hard
it was to be me like what went into that
i respect those spells and i respect the
rogans and i respect
burke prices not you know we don't get
paid to get on stage and crack jokes we
do that for free that shit's free we get
paid for getting on a plane losing our
luggage having to get up at five in the
morning dealing with an uber driver that
don't speak english not to mention he's
got a stink coming out of his armpit
that you can't even sit in the back seat
you got to open up both windows and it's
winter time you know these are the
things they don't pay me to go on stage
i do that for free i do that because i
[__] love it i get paid it's like
when you shoot a movie you get what
scale 680 a [__] day
oh [__]
the power is back on there you go see
how see what happens guys just got to be
[__] patient everybody was jumping up
and down mike came he's like people
going to hear the compressor listen what
do they rather hear the compressor or
the podcast on a monday this is monday
this is liberation here but they've got
so much work goes into being a [__]
stand-up comic you know when you have a
band
when you have five guys in the band like
i just i just heard something that mick
jagger books all his own plane tickets
like he books the bands playing tickets
and [__] like that you know there's
people that are very hands-on i was very
hands-on people always said to me well
you need an assistant that's what i need
a [__] assistant i can't have
i couldn't tell somebody what to do you
know what i'm saying like oh can you
pick up my dry clean you know what an
assistant is in hollywood for you people
who are going to college and going well
i'll get my job as an assistant now meet
people no you're not going to mean
nobody you're not you're going to meet
other dog walkers
that's who you're going to meet when
you're walking dogs you're going to meet
other assistants when you go to the dry
cleaners to pick up some jerk-off shirts
that's who you're gonna meet
you're gonna meet the plumber
on a saturday when he's out of town at a
concert
and you had plans for your girlfriend
but his pipes broke and you got to go to
his house and call a [__] plumber and
wait there like a [__] slave because
that's basically what
a [__] assistant is to you i didn't
want somebody i could tell what to do
that does not sound cool to me at all
when people call me and they're like i
have my assistant call you i'm like i
hope he doesn't because i'm done doing
business with you who you know it's like
when a comedian has an assistant
that tells you a lot about that [__]
person i don't want to be around that
[__] assistant i got a guy that
helps me out but i don't need a guy
getting me [__] water i don't need a
guy walking my dog i don't need a guy
you know what i'm saying i wouldn't do
that to somebody that's just [__] uh
cold-blooded [__] but anyway i don't
know what the [__] we're talking about
there it's monday we got six weeks left
in the [__] year
i've had a lot of time to think lately
i've had a lot of time to think about my
life
you know the things i did what was wrong
on top of that i'm writing a [__]
book
which you get daily reminders of your
life and you know now i'm we're past a
lot of [__]
we're on the chapters where we just meet
terry we're like on 2003 and stuff like
that you know
i was looking at the outline she sent me
some chapters this weekend erica i i
love her to death she's doing a [__]
phenomenal job
and she sent me some chapters and you
got to read them you know you got to sit
there and read them it takes a while and
i wasn't doing much so i was just
[__] uh reading the chapters
and i started reading like the earlier
chapters just to see how it's flowing i
think she sent me like i don't know four
chapters
and then i had i wanted to read the four
prior to see how it's flowing you know
it took about an hour no big [__]
deal
but i got to the chapter
about quitting cocaine
and i was reading through it
and i had to stop
like i had to stop
take my glasses off stretch my eyes and
i had to go what the [__] am i reading
the [__] i was reading
was something that yes i recognize and
yes
i understood it
but it was so real that it brought
memories back to me like i was like what
the [__] you know
like i still remember one of my low
points on drugs
she didn't even know it until this day
she doesn't know
i had terry drive me the cop one night i
was so [__] paranoid at four in the
morning
and i made up some [__] story and i'm
like terry you gotta drive me to this
guy's house i gotta get weed
i can't drive i had alcohol on my breath
i was coked out to the max
thank god it was dark out you know she
couldn't really
i mean she i could catch her staring at
me looking at my face to see what the
[__] was going on with this kid
but you know she drove me and when i
went inside it had to be [__] 4 30 in
the morning
you know when i came out i got in the
[__] car and
we drove away she didn't know but in the
back of my mind she did know
you know we went home she went to bed
i did my junkies [__] and i went to bed
you know eight hours later in the
daytime or something
and a few days later she asked me
she goes why were you in there so long
you know the cops drove by one time and
i was like you know it just happens when
you go in they were playing the nintendo
game or whatever i i don't know what
excuse i told her
but i got to tell you something i read
that chapter the other day like i just
read a few paragraphs
and it just kicked me in the stomach you
know i quit cocaine i didn't celebrate
it this year on the podcast so we're
going to celebrate it now i quit cocaine
november 3rd
2007.
i remember that i started to quit in uh
like february 2007
and i i still remember saying this to
myself i still remember where i was how
i was sitting
i had a notebook on i was journaling and
i'm like i really want to get off coke
in my journal every day and at that time
i would i would write the journal but i
would also include
uh weekly goals and daily goals and i
started doing the daily goals
because i really wanted to get the coke
away from me so i had to reiterate it
every morning
i would get up and write you know i want
to be healthy
i want to quit doing cocaine i want to
you know improve my stand up and i i
want to keep writing and you know
everything i wrote i remember that i
would zero in
on what like five or
six of the daily goals and five of them
were golds that i wanted to reach but i
knew
i could not reach while i was doing
cocaine like i
like i remember looking at him and going
this is [__] ridiculous that i'm
writing this out
because i'm just going to keep doing it
again today but i didn't matter to me i
kept writing it and writing it every day
daily goals quick cocaine
be a better boyfriend you know [__]
uh
kill at the comedy store everything
that i really wanted
wasn't gonna happen until i quit cocaine
and i remember that
marilyn martinez died november 3rd it's
the same day as rick ramos birthday
god bless her soul i was headed to new
york
i came to new york to do the hoboken
police department benefit and the north
bergen basketball team benefit
and
i'm not gonna lie to nobody that friday
that saturday
friday night i had the hoboken benefit i
was surrounded by cops
you know i did my thing a couple friends
went down to see me
and i remember that i made a promise
that weekend i said
i'm gonna go do this thing for the cops
sorry about that i'm gonna do this thing
for the basketball team
and i'm gonna really really really try
not to get high i was really upset about
maryland i wasn't in my hotel room
crying or nothing
but i was upset about marilyn because
she had told me like two weeks earlier
when i went to visit her
they sent her home to die you know
and i went to visit her
and she was talking to me about whatever
you know about comedy that she came back
to comedy she wasn't gonna curse i still
remember that conversation
i was sitting really close to her she
was in one of those medical beds and it
was
you know up like that i'll never forget
that she looked at me we were talking
about just general you know like she's
like the hospital suck the food you know
whatever
and then she said to me you know i'll
stand up going and i go it's good the
store misses you and she goes you know
if i ever get to do comedy again god
wants me to do clean comedy
and i'm like holy [__]
this chick is dying she's talking about
god and [__] you know like i'm like what
the [__]
and she just kept telling me what she
was gonna do if she beat cancer she was
gonna do comedy she was gonna be clean
she was gonna lose weight she's gonna
take care of herself
she was gonna do all these things she
said that she had been slipping with her
life
and that's why she got the cancer and
[__] like that and that she didn't want
to die
we had a great [__] chat and in the
middle of all that chat
she was talking about god
and you guys know when people mention
god i get [__] nervous it's like a
[__] with a whistle i just i don't like
it
i got a friend that talks about god all
the time i love him daily every time we
talk on the phone
he throws like 20 guards at me and [__]
and i'm like wow
but i love him to death and i gotta
[__] put up with it but that's his
bag so
i don't even know what the [__] i was
talking about but anyway uh
no no i was just [__] around
you know people who talk about god a lot
drive me [__] crazy somebody and
marilyn i love marilyn dearly she's
telling me all this [__]
about what her plans are and in the
middle of all this she goes
and god wants you to stop doing cocaine
and i remember looking at her and going
where the f [__] did that come from
but i was like okay marilyn i'll work on
it she's not no no god wants you to stop
doing it joey and there was people in
the room
nobody heard her say it to me but i was
kind of embarrassed because
she was just doing what a good friend
would do she was like these are the
reasons why you got a quick coke you
know you have god wants you to quit coke
you got to quit you know these are the
reasons why
you're gonna be a better person you're
gonna be a better comic and all this
[__] i'm like i don't see that you know
i didn't see that not that i didn't see
becoming a better comic or a better
person
i never saw myself quitting coke
it just had such a hold of me and by the
time that [__] happened with marilyn i
was already experimenting i was already
experimenting what the [__] is wrong
with me i was already doing heroin on
monday nights i mean i was [__] down
you know
but i remember being in that i was in a
hotel room in sea caucus new jersey at
uh i forget those hotels what they
called it wasn't the best hotel in the
world
it was it wasn't even a motel six it was
something else and i remember sitting
there going what the [__]
you know when i got the call at maryland
i'm like what the [__] and i had called
my buddy to start looking for [__]
blow already i go look around you know
let me know if you could find something
it was friday night
i was coming back from hoboken
and that's when i got the call that
maryland had passed i remember i got
back to my hotel room
and i'm like wow marilyn went you know
this is not good blah blah blah you know
i felt bad for her husband
you know marilyn was good at the comedy
store she was great at the comedy store
i felt bad for the store they were gonna
move lose
you know lose a good soldier and i
remember my friend calling me going
listen
i get the package but i can be there at
midnight and i remember sitting there
closing my eyes and going
you know what
i'm going to not do coke tonight
for maryland i didn't say that to him
i said it to myself i go i'm not going
to do coke tonight
tonight
november 3rd i'm not going to do coke
just for maryland
and i remember that i hung up the phone
with him and i'm like [__] i made a
mistake you know like [__]
and i'm like you know what let's try it
let's try it smoke a joint
watch some tv do something different i
remember like at one in the morning i
was like
it wasn't that bad
and i went to sleep
sadly i woke up and my friends were
picking me up we're going to eat this
that the cemetery
and i remember i went to do my show in
north bergen that night and
where i could get coke
was right there
like three guys came and they're like we
got a package if you need it i'm like
okay good to know
and i remember that i went into the back
they didn't have a green room this
wasn't like a comedy club and i went in
my pocket and i took out like whatever
125 bucks he said he had a half eighth
or something like that
and i remember i put it like i separated
from the other money and put it in my
right pocket so i can make the drug
transaction nice and clean you know i'm
saying just give it to him put it right
back in my pocket
and i remember i bumped into him like
twice like after the [__] comedy show
we talked a little bit and i kept
telling him give me 10 minutes i'm
waiting for a friend of mine to call me
to see if i should pick up an eight ball
or whatever i told him that like two or
three times i finally go you know what
i'm in sea caucus
he'll take any any any of these drug
dealers will take him 15 minutes to
bring it to me again i'm not gonna buy
it
i'm just gonna [__]
go home
and if i need it i'll just call him
he'll bring it i went home that night
started packing thought about my week
upcoming
fell asleep got up got on the plane and
came home
i'm on the plane ride from newark to l.a
i was like i can't believe
i didn't get high two nights in a row
guys that might not be anything to you
but at that time
i couldn't keep it together for more
than a [__] day
i was at that point already
i was trying to space it out two days
three days and i get high again you know
i was telling somebody asked me how am i
feeling lately about three weeks ago
and i said i'm feeling great
but
my mind feels like i did coke last night
like i couldn't grab the focus whenever
i did coke tonight before i wouldn't
have good comedy sets it was just a
given like my sets were going to be 50
you know i don't because when you do
stand up
you have to that those words have to go
through your heart that's the you you
ever have like a stereo system and you
have to adjust the bass and the treble
and the volume all that [__] and then
your
music sounds good when you do stand up
comedy you have to do the same thing you
have to adjust the levels to your heart
because the material the the jokes pass
through your heart if you got no heart
it doesn't have a [__] filter
and that's why aerosmith
was having a hard time performing live
all those years black sabbath was having
a hard time performing live all those
years
tell you they'll tell you what you know
ringo starr you remember ringo starr for
years and the friends have put together
[__] tours and [__] like that they
never finished the tour because
everybody gets coked out
ringo starr put out a [__] tour and a
live concert that he sued the production
company because he didn't want it the
air because everybody was so [__]
coked out and so wasted
this is no [__] joke you know it's
it's funny you know everybody goose on
ringo starr
you know that ringo starr is great i
love ringo just the fact that he's still
alive he's got a great [__] attitude
this guy knows he was the luckiest man
in the [__] world there's some people
who walk around their whole [__] life
they didn't really they accomplished
something but they
like me
listen i started acting like stand-up i
just got lucky but with the acting it
was because of big [__] and the
sopranos everybody wanted a double big
big [__]
and i was right there to fill the
[__] void and listen i got my foot in
the [__] door
so what am i going to complain what i'm
going to eat i'm saying like what am i
gonna [__] cry about it
so
when i [__] got back to l.a i'm like
i don't know how i'm gonna keep this
going this two days
two [__] days that was now i had
already met with those guys for
boilermaker i did this movie boilermaker
that i [__] loved the movie i loved
the script when they came to me it was
supposed to be a big budget production
but then they went on they could only
come up that that movie's so funny
boilermaker
because the guy that set that whole deal
up
was a guy listen to let me just tell you
about l.a okay for that this is funny
you're gonna you guys are gonna love
this story
i'm a [__] creep you understand me i
put guns to people's heads i've done
some shitty [__] things when i was
young that was a long [__] time ago
today i'm a nice christian [__] man
or whatever you want to say i get i i
don't bother nobody
this [__] this is why i say to
you guys that
hollywood people are just [__] nuts
and they'll do anything
and last year like i'm still
i'm gonna do a podcast pretty [__]
soon i'm gonna lay it out for you
[__]
like i'm still a little pissed about
what they did to the leah and those guys
last year i'm not
i'm i'm [__] furious that
they went after delia especially knowing
that delia was slinging dick
every [__] night and it wasn't the
leah that was on it wasn't like he was
addicted to sex women were throwing
themselves at [__] crystalia i'm sick
and tired of hearing this [__] about oh
well
even with me well joey got his dick
what do you think those women
were forced to suck a dick those women
knew exactly what they were gonna
[__] do okay and i'll get [__] 10
people to come in here and tell you the
[__] same story if you don't know
hollywood shut your [__] mouth about
it you don't know how creepy it is you
don't know how what what the extent of
what people would do
who would [__] harvey weinstein have you
taken a good look at [__] harvey
weinstein
you have a look at a guy i don't know if
you're a guy or a female if you're a guy
you would look at a guy and go robert
redford is a good looking [__] dude
doesn't take a genius to look at brad
pitt and go
that [__] get his dick sucked
anywhere he won he got his dick sucked
on a blind farm you know what i'm saying
that there's just some [__] not
even a man will go that doesn't mean i'm
gay or i have feelings for the guy i'm
just saying you look at a guy and you're
like you know you gotta admit chris
cornell was a good looking dude him
being able to sing and play the guitar
put him over the top they just throwing
[__] at him you know they just thrown
at him like a [__] frisbee you know
but the creepiness of l.a what happened
the last two years where all these
people get waking up and saying that
this guy did this to me and this guy did
that to me let me tell you something you
put yourself in a bad position
let's dig deep into this [__]
situation what were you doing at that
comedy club anyway dog i could tell you
stories for hours about women that went
up there looking for something to do to
suck a dick to advance their careers
that's what they were doing with harvey
weinstein when you look at harvey
weinstein even if you're a guy you look
at him and go jesus christ he's a bit
rough you could tell his feet smell you
could tell his ass [__] stinks it's
like looking at me you're like joey's
feet stink i can tell by looking at him
he's a fat dude his [__] definitely
[__] smells he talks about
restaurants and [__] all the time you
know his balls stay you know you you
ever just look at something i could tell
that dude's got stinky [__] breath or
whatever you know you could tell [__]
uh
whatever his [__] name is harvey
weinstein's a [__] pig
but guys the fact remains the same
women sucked his
dick to get on [__] tv and film
that's the bottom line guys
you can never take that away from him he
didn't put a gun to their head nobody
said anything about guns or whatever it
was just a straight up deal i got a roll
for you
you sniffed my nut sack the roll is
yours
you know let me go home and think about
it two days later they come back with
banaca
you know with their head down with one
eye on you i think i want to do it but
i'm not sure i've never done this before
no you've never done this before you've
been working mental your [__] life
you know and now you're working at the
extreme [__] uh height that you could
do it and that's what's going on in
[__] hollywood but let me tell you
the other side
the guy that got this movie
you ready for this got a dui
got arrested
he got court-ordered
you know uh
dui therapy and he got court-ordered
uh
aaa meetings
he went to a couple a.a meetings
and he realized
that a lot of industry was there
so what he did was
he [__] did the program for 90 days
did the [__] whatever this guy had
big money so he paid the attorney got
off whatever i'm not mad at that
not mad at anything to be honest i'm
just telling you
what people will do
this guy was getting high i still
remember him like being at gigs and
going
he was like a manager and he would come
to see his clients
and i still remember like
him drinking having a conversation with
him and him going oh [__] i can't drink
tonight
and i'm like what do you mean you can't
drink i can't have alcohol on my breath
i gotta go to a nine o'clock a.a meeting
and i'm like
do you drink and go to ia he goes i go
to iaa for the connection she can't beat
him
he goes all you people are [__]
stupid he goes just fake it go to the
[__] meetings
you know tell him that you are trying to
get sober from coke and whatever and
they you know theo vaughn met what's the
guy that was raping kids and [__] he the
peop
the guy from american beauty
oh uh
yeah
yeah the guy who was [__] he got
canceled for [__] uh you know the guy
who played kaiser so say whatever that
guy theo von was hanging out with him he
met him at aaa
i don't know if you got you know
a.a in hollywood is a wide open [__]
to shoot him up but anyway this guy
would go
to meetings
kevin spacey you know yeah theo was
friend i remember calling theo one
morning i gotta call you back i'm having
breakfast with kevin space i'm like
kevin [__] spacey how did you meet
kevin spacey like i met him at aa
meetings i'm like what the [__] you know
i tried to go to a few a.a meetings in
l.a when i was first trying to get clean
they're not good they're [__] fun you
know i like the new work meetings in 85
mr t took me to a couple meetings in
newark oh my god
those aaa meetings are raw people like i
drank a pint a day and people would yell
[__] you
i was doing a gallon of vodka shut the
[__] up you [__] [__] i was eating
pills i was snorting heroin and you're
in here for a pint of vodka go [__]
yourself i'd be [__] holland but in a
a it's like this [__] fake scene like
hi how are you
i've been clean for [__] you know
three weeks and
my burps still smell like sperm you know
the whole [__] deal
you know so i went to a couple of aaa
meetings and i'm like that this is not
gonna work
but he would go to aaa meetings to
[__] uh
connections and [__] and that's how he
picked up the i'm not mad at him
but i want you to think of what was done
here and then i saw
the show i was on on showtime about
comedy store
you know
uh
i'm dying up here whatever and i think
one of the guys
for stage time
used to go to aaa meetings and just get
up there and do 10 minutes and [__] and
then they got mad at him
but then you know you look at that
that's completely i don't know if that's
[__] different
but then you know what guys when i was a
[__] open micro there was a poetry
meeting
and i used to crash the poetry meetings
i would go in there with like a skinny
cigarette
you know and just like yeah like a capri
sun the the white
capri whatever the [__] yeah i can't
believe you remember capri they're
little [__] cigarettes they're skinny
oh you don't know how many nights i ran
out of camel lights when you're doing
coke and you got to go for that [__]
somebody else's i used to get high with
this chick all the time oh my god she
used to drive me crazy i didn't even go
over there for sex i just kind of liked
her to talk to her on drugs but she was
a boozer she would wear me the [__] out
many at night i was over there smoking
camel lights i'd run out of cigarettes
and start smoking a little [__] capris
oh my god they got me dizzy and gave me
a headache and they were [__] skinny
and [__] you over there [__] sucking
the [__] capri like the penguin i
would show up at those [__]
poetry reading is in boulder but that's
completely different
a aaa meeting has got god around them
like you're looking for a higher power
and all that [__] so
i had to take a minute from the podcast
to talk to you about better help online
therapy i've been working with dana now
for about five months from the beginning
of my taper and she's been nothing but
knowledgeable
helpful and tremendous
we talk about better help a lot on this
show and this month we're discussing
some of the stigmas around mental health
many people think therapy is for
so-called crazy people or weak people
but therapy doesn't mean there's
something wrong with you it means that
you're recognizing your emotions and
you're ready to learn to control them
like i had to therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse
better help is customized online therapy
they offer phone video and even live
chat sessions with your therapist in my
case it was dana you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you don't need to be a
millionaire and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
less than 48 hours give it a try go to
betterhelp betterhelp.com right now
preston diaz and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to give you
the first month 10 percent off your
first month when you go to
betterhelp.com
diaz that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot-com
slash diaz take control of your life i
did and i'm feeling 100 better thank you
for watching the joint [__]
you know
it just bothered me but i remember when
i went to meet with those guys for the
movie
and it wasn't him in the room because he
would never say this to me and one of
the guys said you know
you have a
drug abuse problem a substance problem
and we want to know
that you're gonna have it in check
during this movie and i remember that i
felt like [__]
when he told me that i was very [__]
embarrassed about that because i didn't
want
my drug use to fall into my comedy and
into my acting but at that point it had
stand-up was affecting you know towards
the end of the longest yard my
relationship with them
was not any good my relationship was
intact with adam but the producers knew
about my substance abuse problem and i
just shunned it off you know
and when i went to talk to these guys
about boilermaker if you could find the
movie rented it's not a bad movie i did
a good job in the movie that's the first
time i was really
um loose in a movie
i had to be that 20
i don't know one days in a row
for this movie so when they offered me
the movie
that was the
yeah that was the [__] i was like i
don't know if i could do this
and
i wanted to talk about this today
but i didn't in a way but i thought that
i've been reading a lot of the messages
again lately a couple people on patreon
a couple people on facebook people
twitter you know reach out to me
and people are struggling with drugs
they're finally coming to the conclusion
that they're
struggling with drugs this last two
years
has been very hard on some people it was
hard on me i struggled for a little
while
so i know that it was hard for a lot of
people so i want to just uh
let you know that you're you're not
alone and that you could beat this
you know i thought about this last night
about the podcast how i was gonna
present this to you
the name of this podcast is called how
you can beat this
because the thought you know the thing
that kills us the most as human beings
is when we go to do our goals we
think about them and while we're writing
them
we real i got to be honest with you guys
when i started first started writing
goals and doing all this type of [__] i
thought i was just kidding myself and i
thought that
i never thought i'd be on tv i never
thought you know when i tell you these
things guys
i'm honest with you guys i was in such a
bad shape mentally i mean stan my
stand-up was good
i was attentive i was enthusiastic
but i never thought i could do anything
because of my drug record because of
where i came from and because of my
felonies and that was a bad that
stinking thinking is what they call that
[__] right they call like stinking
thinking
sorry about the water bottle guys but
it's part of growing the [__] up you
know but i can't get away from what i'm
gonna do pack a class with ice cubes and
then you complain about the [__] ice
cubes
if i get a [__] lunch thing one of
those canteens you're complaining about
the [__] canteen so at the end of the
day you're gonna complain about
everything so who gives a [__] let me
drink my water in peace and get hydrated
here so i can have a good week like you
[__]
but my point being is that uh
i just you know don't ever when you're
thinking about your sobriety when you're
thinking about
your goals when you're thinking about
the things that you want to do
don't write yourself off i did that i
wrote myself off and listen i still got
to the places where i wanted to get to
because i consistently wrote my goals
every [__] day
you know like right now i'm going to go
into deep waters i'm putting myself into
deep orders i got to change my life
around
i'm very close
so what do i have to do i got to start
writing daily goals yeah i journal yeah
i do quality goals but you know what
starting tomorrow [__] starting today
as a matter of fact with this podcast
ends
i'm going to start the daily ghosts
because it's monday and daily goals
could be anything but my daily goal for
years
was to quit cocaine and then i would put
down quick cocaine
how are you going to quit cocaine
that was the [__] thing i didn't know
the three things to answer that's the
other side of writing your goals
when you write your goals
it's so number one
quick cocaine
a b and c how are you gonna quit what
things what three things are you gonna
do to quit do you know what the crazy
thing with me is
i can never fill out a b and c
so for me on a daily basis
when i wrote out my goals of quick
cocaine
i didn't even know how to start
to get there how do you quit cocaine
you go to aaa i tried that
you go to na i tried that
you go to a rehab i tried that i tried
an outpatient rehab not a six week in
there with a bunch of momos
chanting kumbaya i mean i tried you know
i tried all that you tried talking to a
priest they wouldn't even take my calls
anymore i talked to so many [__]
priests
so i wouldn't write anything down i
didn't even know
where to start i remember that one day
like in november
when i came from maryland's that sunday
that next day i thought about i go okay
[__] marilyn
hit me with a message from god
you know like a message in a bottle she
was like [__] uh you know the singer
from the police she gave me a little
message from god okay how am i gonna do
this
and i remember writing down the [__]
most cliches gayest thing ever
i wrote one day at a time
i don't even know why i wrote that i
just
i didn't think i hey enough and i just
wrote one day at a time am i gonna quit
this
one day at a [__] time
and i remember i came back i had three
days of being [__] sober
and i got back on a sunday
and monday morning i was four days of
being sober
and i felt like i had [__] spiders in
my skin
i'm like this just doesn't feel good man
and i was looking at the calendar like
that friday i had a spot that thursday i
had a spot and i'm like
i don't think i'm gonna make these
[__] spots i just don't think i'm
gonna do this [__]
so i said [__] it i'm gonna start
shooting a movie on thursday that movie
started on a thursday i got back from
jersey on monday
that movie started on a [__] thursday
and i'll never forget that i was like
it was three weeks from thanksgiving we
were gonna end
the day after thanksgiving so that
friday
and i was like how the [__]
am i gonna [__] stay sober for three
[__] weeks
i got it
i'll buy a bottle of nyquil i'll pull a
j more
i'll buy a bottle of nyquil and nyquil
myself to death
every time i have a [__] craving
you know every time i have a [__]
craving
so i did the nyquil trick
thursday night i think i did the nyquil
trick on wednesday night
and i did the [__] night wolf trick
on
a friday night
yeah
it makes sense now
and that [__]
saturday night
i [__] went to the comedy store
and they were having a benefit from
maryland that monday
i'll never forget i'm like how am i
gonna [__]
hold it together
and that saturday night
i said [__] it i'm not going to hold it
together
i went and i got a package at the store
one little package just a quick 50.
just something to and nobody would know
i was like i'm not gonna be able to
[__] do this
and i'll never forget i got in the car
i closed the car and as i got to the
bottom of the hill the phone rang
and it was my wife and she goes listen
i'm going to bed i got to get up early
but when you come home
and you go to the bathroom
the two cats are in there they're not
doing too good and i'd be surprised that
they made the night
it was super bad and [__] uh jt
whatever demi junior
dj jt
dj
and i was like what the [__] are you
talking about i was heartbroken in the
car about dj
i was about two or three weeks from
bringing dj up to the [__] apartment
he was just a little kid
super bad i wasn't too [__] crazy
about i did not like him at all because
he would make dj
run off and climb trees and [__] i'm
like i'm gonna kill this [__] cat one
day
i'd wake up in the mornings and
super bad would have dj out in the
[__] sidewalk i had a fence there and
he would have him on the sidewalk
like all these cats are gonna get hit by
a [__] car i gotta bring this
[__] up too late
my wife called me i was headed back from
the store and she's like like i said
when you come up the stairs and you walk
in the bathroom be careful when you open
the door
because the two cats are in there
and i remember i went home
and i [__]
i did a line
in the bathroom
and i put the coke away i put it all in
my pocket and i remember looking at the
two cats
and going what the [__]
am i doing with my life
i got two cats that are about to die in
my bathroom and i'm doing [__] coke
in the bathroom
i would never ever bring coke upstairs
i always would bring the package
pull into my garage than it was in the
garage it was an outdoor garage there
was no door that went up or down you
just pulled into it i don't know if you
guys look at the old joey karate videos
those garages
those were the garages and i pulled in i
would pull in at night i got no reason
to lie to you [__] i would buy
a gram of the strongest coke you'd get
your hands on
and i would pick it up two blocks away
and on the way home at the first light
which was
not lebret
but it was the next street after the
break guys you're gonna have to remind
me
the big main street and i would pull up
to the
light and they would usually be a car in
front of me and there was a gap it was
fountain and whatever the street was
there was a gas station over there
uh
we were talking about
marky mark before his family at
warburg's their sandwich place
the wall burgers is right there on that
street so it's like
whatever there used to be a sushi place
there there was a yogurt place there but
now today just to give you a landmark
there's a [__] uh
warburger's is there at that light
i would crunch up as i was driving to
that light he would give me a bundle
like a baggie with one coke rock in
there maybe a little tenta powder and i
would crack that soft rock up with my
hands because if the rock is hard it's
been re-rocked if it's soft it's the
real deal mongolia feel that's delivered
from pablo that way so i would get the
rock crushing in my [__] finger
roll up a dollar bill and at the light
with a car in front of me in a car
behind me i put the dollar bill in the
bag and i just put it up to my nose and
go
and whatever i snorted i snorted if
three quarters of the bag went up three
quarters of the bag went up if a half of
the bag went up a half of the bag went
up
i didn't give a [__]
i would [__] just uh
do that and then
um
when i pull into the house i'd have a
little bit of the [__] juice in me
you know what i'm saying
i'd have a little bit of the juice in me
and i'd [__] uh when i pull into the
garage i'd close the gate and i'd go to
my garage and i'd finish the other half
of the bag and then i'd run upstairs and
i'd take a two foot [__] from all the
coke and the adrenaline running through
your veins and [__]
so that's exactly what i did that night
i did a little bump upstairs but for
some reason i brought the coke with me
in my pocket i ran up the [__] stairs
and i uh
opened the bathroom and i went to [__]
and there was super bad and dimmy
and i had the last [__]
uh bindle and i [__] did a [__]
line in front of the cats
and i remember how bad i felt like i was
out there all night just feeling [__]
terrible you know i'm like
how can i bring this into my [__]
house
so i took the coke i flushed it
and i said that's it
and i jumped in my [__] bed and i
went to sleep my wife woke me up in the
morning
and she's like joe i just want to tell
you
that
dj died
while you were sleeping
i was about to bring dj up
i told her just to close the door and i
was [__] heartbroken as [__]
i went i said [__] this she goes what do
you want me to do with super bad i go i
i don't know
and i remember getting up
going in the bathroom getting on my
hands and knees and going god you know
what
i don't like this [__] cat at all but
he can't die
he can't die he took one cat because i
did coke in the apartment i would never
do coke upstairs
i broke the rule one time and you took a
[__] cat you can't take the other cat
if it means me not snorting coke i'm
making you this promise right now
i'll never [__] snort coke again
and that was it i remember going to
sleep
waking up that afternoon doing coke
not doing coke
doing comedy that night and i remember
that i had
three weeks to shoot that movie i was
petrified as [__]
you know i think back now i was scared
of getting clean
how [__] crazy is that like
i was scared of getting clean
you know
i know there's a lot of you guys
struggling right now
with opioids or drinking or
the pills and i know that when you wake
up in the morning you look at the
ceiling
and you say to yourself this is never
gonna [__] end
i'm never gonna get away from this
[__]
[__] but guess what
you are you know why
because i did
and if
i mean guys i remember snorting coke and
my [__] spine hurting my spine would
give me electrical jolts
my whole [__] body would joke like
that that's
not a good feeling and that's what i
walked away from
and i'm just [__] happy i did guys
you know so
this monday the 15th of november is uh
dedicated
to my 14 years of sobriety i never
thought i could [__] do it i never
thought i could do it guys i'm
honest to god and listen i've had some
really bad things happen to me
i've been involved in some very bad
things that i've created along the way
nothing bad just happens to you you know
all these people i was walking down the
street
and a black guy following me you know it
just doesn't happen that way you had to
be doing something you know saying it
don't happen that way [__] second
so
[Laughter]
you know uh
and a lot of things life just imposed on
me and [__] but this
i had to do this and i think about my
life i think about you know taping the
netflix special
taping the special with those other
[__] moocs
i think about doing theaters which i
never thought about in the beginning i
think about
the longest shot i think about so many
great [__] things i think about
my daughter being born me getting
engaged to my wife
a lot of great [__] things happened
but if
i have to look at the single most best
thing that have happened to me was
getting off of drugs
i gotta tell you some guys it feels
great to smoke a joint at night it feels
great
not to smoke pot all [__] day it
feels great
not to be addicted to something whether
it's a [__] anxiety pill cocaine
whatever
it feels great that nothing's got to
hold on you i don't know how your life
is today
or what you're doing i'm nobody to
[__] talk i'm just here to help you
get through today that's
what this podcast is about this is
entertainment i'm just a fat [__]
felon and this is just
about us getting through today
it's 2022 and six weeks if you're still
[__] around with drugs
it's time to clean your [__] act
you know i give thanks if i have to be
lucky enough
jen i hate saying this word because a
lot of you guys don't like it god or the
upper power i know a lot of you guys
don't want to hear it but if i have to
be thankful for one [__] thing
and you all got to witness it
i'm thankful
that i was never snorting coke
and three people died
when i was around
i mean i'm i'm happy that i never
[__]
killed nobody in a car and i was high on
coke
or anything like that but i got to be
honest with you and that happened to
kate quigley
i can't tell you how thankful
i [__] was
that that situation never happened to me
and dog
kate quigley's 37 years old she started
doing coke later on in life
the odds of it happening to kate quigley
or it happened to me were greater for me
because the distance the amount of time
i did coke
but you know what after that happened to
kate quigley i was like thank god
i never did coke again thank [__] god
i think beaumont texas where i oded
because in 2005 that's when i started
thinking about quitting
so it took me two years to quit after
thinking about it for two years
so i know you think you're struggling
i know you think you're never gonna get
off this [__] whether it's booze
[__] drugs pills whatever the [__]
but let me tell you something if i got
off coke i'm a [__] [__]
and if i got off coke without going to
rehab if i got a coke i got off coke
because i had to move the [__] forward
and it was holding me back and that's
what any of these drugs do to you
2022 is here we're six weeks away which
means it's here in two weeks we're gonna
hit thanksgiving and after that the
[__] times are gonna roll and next
you know it's gonna be new year's day
get started preparing for it today
that's it
you want 22 to be a [__] great year
prepare yourself right now what you want
to happen what your goals are
and what things you're going to kick out
of your [__] life to move forward
you know i got these two cousins
that i grew up with in miami and i love
them dearly you know
i talked to one and i text with the
other guy
but both of them are [__] up
we all had the same thing happen to us
we all had the same childhoods
we all had the same type of parents
and our parents died you know my parents
died the first and then the one guy
his parents died like 20 years later and
then my cousin cousin
the kid that uh you know me and him grew
up together pretty much
his parents his mother just recently
died
and i the difference between me and them
is that they're stuck
they got stuck in that
void you know i have a lot of friends in
north bergen that are still stuck in the
80s the 90s
they can't jump out of that i think me
quitting coke
unstuck me
so i think by you quitting whatever drug
you're doing whether it's booze or
whatever
i think you'll be unstuck whenever the
kid from florida hits me up
it's because he's drinking after he'll
text me 10 times i'll call him up and go
knock it off with the text what the [__]
is going on and we'll talk and he's
drinking so i think that
any substance
could keep you stuck i'm i'm happy that
i stopped on november 3rd
of 2007
i'm grateful every day that i stop
and i'm grateful that one of you
[__] stop and that's the
podcast
for monday
the 15th of november i don't know what
else to [__] tell you [__]
just get ready 2022 is coming and i'm
[__] excited i haven't been this
excited in a long [__] time i
love you [__] with all my heart
packwoods is selling out of laughing gas
like a [__] i'm hearing great
things the second batch is deadly i gave
some to mikey there to take home for the
next couple days
and that's it and that's that i love you
[__]
with all my heart uh have a great
[__] monday
and we'll be back wednesday
the 17th what are you ready for this one
that's the day
thursday will be
november 18th is the day i [__]
kidnapped
ken bella so that we have another
anniversary november's field anniversary
mother's debt
quitting cocaine kidnapping vela
you know give or take my santeria i got
inducted in the 28th of the month
that'll put me at 52 years it's a great
month november i love you [__]
stay tip top magoo
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you
for watching or listening to the joint
today i'm excited
14 years no cocaine how the [__] would
you feel
tremendous the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy we talk about
better help a lot on the show and this
month we're discussing some of the
stigmas around mental health
listen man i was stuck you guys know
that all you got to do is listen to a
podcast in january
february or march and uh you could tell
there was something wrong with me but
i'll tell you what i contacted better
help i started talking to a therapist
named dana
we talked once a week early morning and
it's been fantastic you know many people
think therapy is for so-called crazy
people but it's not it doesn't mean
there's something wrong with you means
that you recognize
that we have emotions and we gotta learn
to control them not avoid them
therapy is a tool to utilize before
things get worse if i would have known
what i know now i would have been
talking to somebody while i was doing
stand-up in l.a and i tried to but i
just couldn't make monday night so now
i'm all in and better help is customize
online therapy don't wait
until you're feeling unbearable
better help office video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
you don't have to see anybody on camera
if you don't want to and it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you can start communicating with your
therapist in less
than 48 hours give better help a shot
today you're going to find out why over
2 million people have used better help
online therapy you're not going to find
a therapist they're all busy the
pandemic
put us all in the whirlwind but you
don't have to feel like this anymore
today go to betterhelp.com diaz that's
betterhelp.com
diaz
take control of your life and get the
help you deserve with better help i'm
going to get you 10 off your first month
when you put in code diaz
that's it and that's that right what
else we got here
all right
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter
listen i don't know if you guys know
there's 10 million people looking for
jobs
only 7.6 million people are looking for
work but there's 10 million job openings
if you have a job open you need to go
above and beyond to get qualified people
zip recruiter can help if you need help
building your team you need to try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey why am i using zip recruiter joy
because they use powerful technology
excuse me to find and match the right
candidates with your job and present
them to you you can easily reuse your re
you can easily review
your recommendations and invite your top
choices to apply
zip recruit is so effective guys that
four out of five employers who post a
quality candidate find them within the
first day that's why they're rated
number one in the us so do me a favor
you can try zip recruiter for free just
go to
ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y that's ziprecruiter.com
joey that's j-o-e-y
zip recruiter the smartest way to hide i
want to thank annette i want to thank
betterhelp.com and i want to thank
ziprecruiter.com
for giving me an opportunity give me and
i want to tell you guys something real
quick
you should get yourself a little freeze
pipe or start following them on twitter
i didn't even know they were on twitter
they got some great things they do with
the freeze pipe on twitter so go to
twitter and friend freeze pipe and
that's it i love you [__] it's
monday the 15th go get what belongs to
you [__] tip top magoo i'll see
you wednesday morning ready to rock
i love you
you